the businesses that I have started have
been ones that were built on skills
because I have lost everything twice and
the biggest realization of my life was
that I didn't lose everything I lost a
fraction of what I thought I had lost
because I still kept onto the thing that
no one could ever take from it which is
the skills and the experiences the
lessons that I had learned through the
path that I well I would pay any amount
of money to make an obvious truth real
for me the most valuable thing that I
had are lessons that I had paid Blood
Sweat tears and money to learn so that I
could apply them to a new reality when I
have zero I applied My New Reality which
was not the reality that I had when I
started my gyms because technically when
I started my first gym I also had zero
so the way I play the game is different
and so if we go back to the definition
of learning which is similar condition
different Behavior so I'm the same
condition except my behavior is
different